this morning Prince Harry and Megan are
kicking off their first official tour as
a family ten days in Africa with their
son Archie the continent and its
challenges hold special significance for
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex Debora
patta reports from Cape Town South
Africa
their first stop the Duke and Duchess
declined the usual pomp and ceremony
associated with visiting royalty getting
down to business within hours after
arriving in Cape Town
earlier this morning here in yunga they
are focusing on violence against women
it's an issue that has dominated
headlines in Cape Town this month after
young South Africans took to the streets
to protest horrifying statistics a woman
is murdered every three hours in this
country royal correspondent Roy Anika
expects this trip will engender even
more goodwill for Megan there have been
some teething problems there's no doubt
about it but I think if she sort of
settled into the role a bit more and
gets her teeth stuck into some more
official world work I'm sure that her
popularity will continue to grow the
couple will have their hands full away
from the public eye as well it's their
first trip as a family four month old
baby Archie is travelling with them
previously the Duke and Duchess have
expressed an interest in spending
several months of each year in Africa
there's no doubt that this kind of trip
will give Harry and Megan as a couple
and a family more of a taste of what
life potentially might be out there
Buckingham Palace has admitted that the
presence of baby Archie makes things a
lot more lively but don't expect to see
too much of him
you'll be looked after by his nanny when
the couple are on official duty although
it's likely it'll make some kind of
appearance in the next few days Gale
propeller we can't wait for the
appearance does he have red hair who
does he look like but the world wants to
know
Thank You Deborah patty I hear he's very
cute